well can't you get cooking in cloud
where we share the best recipes to apply
in your cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka and in this episode I am
pleased to have Jen person back with us
to talk about another mobile app back in
service solution
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning Jen welcome back to get
cooking in cloud thanks Priyanka I'm
super excited to share today's solution
I think it's a real winner so last time
you were on the show you left us in a
bit of a cliffhanger
you shared a mobile app back in service
solution using firebase and App Engine
standard environment my app Priyanka's
kitchen uses avatars and cloud storage
for firebase I need a way to create
thumbnail version zuv larger images I'll
need to be able to download the full
size image scale it download the scaled
version and then right back to cloud
storage that means I will need to write
to the file system but so far you didn't
recommend the recipe for back-end
services that call native binaries right
to the file system or make other system
calls I am really excited to see that
solution today
that's right Priyanka in an earlier
episode I explained that firebase solves
a lot of the mobile app back-end
problems and last episode we saw that
adding app engine standard environment
provides a back-end service to modify
the synchronize data filling a gap in
the firebase only solution but as you
pointed out App Engine standard
environment cannot solve every problem
for your image thumbnail example we
definitely need a different solution are
you ready to see it I'm waiting with
bated breath let's cook it up so again
here's our recipe from the last episode
and here's today's recipe that's right
in this design pattern we still use
firebase for all its mobile app back-end
benefits but instead of App Engine
standard environment we use App Engine
flexible environment I noticed that the
ingredient here is the same app engine
and this looks very similar to last
episode's recipe but it differs an
important way right yes like average and
standard environment App Engine flexible
environment is an app platform that
monitors updates and scales the hosting
environment all you need to do is write
your mobile backend service code those
features are the same where App Engine
standard and flexible environment differ
is that flexible environment runs your
back-end service inside a docker
Taner that you can configure exactly and
this means that you can call native
binaries right to the file system and
make other system calls all the things
you can't do in App Engine standard
environment so if your app needs to
process user data or orchestrate events
extending firebase with App Engine
flexible environment gives you automatic
real time data synchronization without
needing to run your code inside the App
Engine sandbox so this solution is
obviously a bit more flexible yep as the
name implies the App Engine flexible
environment will give you more
flexibility this is a great solution for
firebase apps that need a back-end
service to modify the synchronize data
and that service requires a custom
server configuration or third-party
libraries that aren't supported by App
Engine standard environments aren't
there any other benefits to the flexible
environment there is one more you may
recall that the App Engine standard
environment only holds a connection open
for two minutes
well App Engine flexible environment can
hold a connection open for 24 hours so
for example you can use this
architecture for back-end services that
require a persistent connection to
firebase to receive notifications of
data changes I can totally see how that
would be useful definitely and since you
can write to the file system you can use
this recipe to generate thumbnails for
Priyanka kitchen well that's all for
today on get cooking in cloud gen thank
you so much for coming on the show if
you would like to know more about
today's recipe you can check out the
firebase and App Engine guides reference
Docs the code samples and get home and
the firebase YouTube channel and if you
like this video then check out the other
episodes in the series don't forget to
subscribe to our channel so you can be
notified about new episodes of get
cooking in cloud as well as other great
google cloud content
you